[Music]
new at 11 o'clock Democratic senator
Catherine Cortez masto getting a tour of
a new battery building Facility in
Henderson now right now lithium's
Factory is partially operational they're
making batteries for big things like
planes and for generators Senator masto
crediting her votes for President
Biden's infrastructure and inflation
reduction acts in helping businesses
like this one
this is why for me those Investments are
key that we continue to support them
over the next 10 years because it's
going to bring incredible opportunities
and and businesses like this right here
to Nevada
the company is hiring about 20 people to
fill positions the plant should be fully
operational by the end of the year